well I'm glad to be back I hope you all
had a wonderful Memorial Day mine was
mine was not as wonderful given you know
that I had this little addition to the
family that none would be stuck in this
chair for the rest of the day because
the crutches are over there I I have a
sustained a possibly severe leg injury
which pending MRI results might require
surgery and months of rehab and I did
all of this during my friend's bachelor
party which I know see that's the thing
that's bad about it's so cliche you know
that I would come back from a bachelor
party injured we went to deep creek lake
in Maryland over the for a couple days
for a good friend of mine is getting
married known him for probably 25 years
or so very very excited very happy for
him and and you know the weekend went
well but I did towards the end of the
weekend rupture my Achilles we think you
know still got to wait for the MRI
results to come back but the worst thing
about it is well the worst thing about
it is that my foot is swollen like a
like an ugly foot balloon and I can't
walk on it
and I've been crawling around the house
for the last three days but the second
worst thing about it is that it happened
at a bachelor party but it's it's I have
no cool bachelor party story about it
it's not like I you know I woke up in a
drainage ditch with a sombrero on and a
scuba diving suit or something and my
leg was broken and I didn't know what
happened it wasn't anything like that I
was playing pickup basketball that was
all it was and played a pretty good game
caught a couple you know got a couple
rebounds and made a few points we only
played till 11 so I got like 30 percent
of the points no big deal went up for a
rebound towards the end of the game came
down heard a pop kind of like it's like
a pop slash crunch sound it's almost
like if you if you can imagine jumping
up and landing on an empty shoebox or
something that's that's the only thing I
could compare it to and when I first
heard the sound I thought that was a
weird sound what was that sound and then
I felt excruciating pain and I thought
oh that sound was me I made that sound
somehow and then I fell into the ground
and fast forward go to the emergency
room so on and so forth and
anyway here we are a lot of people have
asked me Matt do you recommend tearing
the Achilles is it a fun experience is
this something that you would like to do
again and I have to say that honestly I
don't like it that much it's not it
hasn't been all that fun surprisingly I
would have to give it a negative yelp
review crutches also I'm not excited
about them
I always thought crutches seemed to be
honest when I saw people on crutches I
used to think those look kind of fun and
but they're not actually it turns out
they they're not fun at all although I
did get a few days ago one of those or
yesterday actually
I got went to the medical supply store I
got one of those nice scooters which is
the newest technology for cripples and
so you can kind of scoot around the
house now that is pretty fun so with
that I'll say when I'm on the knee
scooter I honestly feel bad for you
people who have your intact Achilles
that you don't get to experience the new
scooter you're suckers so in the end
maybe I win all right there's a lot to
have to talk about aside from my medical
issues but before we get to that I wanna
tell you today's podcast is brought to
you by even charile watches no matter
what you consider your style to be
quality classic wristwatch is something
that I think every guy needs there's
always going to be an occasion where you
need it because you want to look sharp
and impress and that little nerdy Apple
watch you know that's not gonna do
you're just wearing a computer on your
wrist alright you've already got one in
your pocket you've got one in your
laptop bag you don't need one on your
wrist - how about just a regular watch
so that's why we're partnering with
Vinci row so you can get a truly
stunning watch at even even more
impressive price exclusive for our
listeners Bench arrows offering an extra
15% off of their exceptionally crafted
watches all you have to do is go to
Finch arrow watches comm that's V I and
CER o watches comm forward slash Walsh
and use code Walsh for 15% off now this
is our first time working with inch
arrows so they were nice enough to send
me one of their one of their watches
that's why I'm wearing this watch right
here now this is called the
Oh No s MOT a gray that's the fancy name
it's really just a gray watch and I've
been wearing it all the time I've been
complimented a bunch of times if if you
know a watch can manage to make me look
good then it can do that for anyone and
so that's that's the best sales pitch I
can give you so as I said I'm wearing
the crowd OS Monta gray but the chair
has dozens of watches to choose from and
I went ahead and picked my top five you
can go to vin chair watches comm forward
slash walsh to see my picks and don't
forget to use code walsh for 15% off go
to VI and see ero watches comm forward
slash walsh and code walsh for 15% off
all right um well this is this is
exciting
robert muller spoke today I said
exciting maybe that's not the right word
I need to check my thesaurus I actually
if I live the rest of my life and never
hear the words Muller or report or those
two combined especially again I will die
a happy man because I'm so tired of the
end of the subject I thought we were
past it in fact I was ready to do the
show today and then it was announced
that Oh Muller is gonna speak ok well I
guess I gotta we gotta wait put off the
show I'm gonna watch the stupid speech
and then talk about it because I just I
don't I get it right I think we all get
it at this point with the Muller thing
if you're an intelligent person if
you've been paying attention if you're
willing to absorb the facts and form
your opinion based on those facts if
you're that kind of person
then you already get it with this you
you you understand the deal and so we
don't need to talk about it anymore we
didn't need another another press
conference which wasn't even really a
press conference because didn't take any
questions but we got one anyway and
according to the media this was what I
kept hearing leading up to the address
from Muller is that this will be the
first time that we hear from Muller
since the investigation began it's gonna
be the first time we hear from him well
call me crazy but I seem to remember
Muller releasing a 400-page report
like a month ago and so he spoke pretty
substantially through that I feel like
this is not the first time we've heard
from him
this is the first time we've heard from
him aside from besides the four hundred
pages worth of stuff that we heard from
him so except for those four hundred
pages yeah this is the first time and he
got up he basically summarized what was
in the report I'm not gonna play any of
the clips because it doesn't matter you
can find those anywhere but I think he
was highlighting two things he was
highlighting number one that the
Russians did interfere in our election
important point one that I think we most
of us already knew and two he also
highlighted that Trump was not
exonerated of obstruction this was not a
he has not been exonerated
Moeller said that if they had found
solid reason to believe that Trump was
innocent of the charges of obstruction
then they would have said so
they did not say so so you know you
could put two and two together there he
explained that a sitting president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
anyway regardless of whether he
committed one and so they weighed that
in their decision their decision not to
sort of accuse him of anything and he
also said it would be unfair to because
if you can't charge a president with a
crime that means there can't be a trial
and so there can't be a trial then if
you just put those accusations out there
there's not going to be any there can't
be a process to figure out if it's true
or not
and so the accused can't really defend
himself in the court of law in that case
so they decide it was unfair and so
that's why they just made the decision
they did to not really address one way
or another whether or not they think the
president committed obstruction which
which seems to possibly imply that if
President Trump was private citizen
Trump they very likely may have charged
him with a crime so what is that what is
this all they mean I think if we're to
summarize it means that when Democrats
say that Trump colluded with the
Russians they're lying because there's
no
evidence of that the report didn't say
that
you can't just accuse him of that as if
you have information that it's true
because you don't okay so that's one
thing but it also means that when
Republicans including Trump himself
claimed that the report was a total
exoneration which of course Trump has
said many times that also is just a lie
it's not Muller is the guy who wrote the
report and he said very clearly it's not
an exoneration not exonerating him so
that's also a lie so people are lying on
both sides and and that's wonderful as
always
now putting putting aside for a minute
one other thing that occurs to me
putting aside Trump and Muller for a
minute just it seems crazy to me that we
can't that you can't charge a president
with a crime that to me is is is
unamerican no matter who the president
is I don't care who it is I don't care
what their party is but that's one
aspect of this that shouldn't be lost as
I said putting Trump to the side just
this the whole idea that in general you
can't charge a president with a crack
well what if a president commits a truck
crime maybe Trump didn't but what if a
president actually does commit a crime
you're telling me that you can't charge
him he so he the president really is
above the law
that to me doesn't make any sense I how
is the president any different from a
dictator in that case how is our system
really that much different from having a
military dictator who is above the law
and cannot be held responsible for what
he does it sounds like we've got a
similar system and I think that there's
some changes need to be made there the
president in the end is just a man like
the rest of us and he should be subject
to the same laws period what else is
there to say here I mean if you as I
said if you are willing to listen to the
facts and form your conclusions based on
those facts then
you've already heard everything that you
need to hear with this the problem is
that of course I think there may be four
or five people in the entire country who
fall into that category everybody else
their opinions are gonna be formed not
really based on the facts but based on
their partisan loyalties based on how
they feel about Trump pro or con and
that sort of thing and that's where
they're gonna form their opinions and
that's probably the main reason why I
find this constant discussion of the
Moller report
so agonizingly painful because it
doesn't matter 99% of the people engaged
in the conversation they already formed
their opinions before there was any
investigation before there was any
report before anything their opinions
have already been formed and not based
on any evidence or facts or anything and
that's how most of our conversations go
about most subjects in this country that
most of the people engaging the
conversation they have there they have
formed those opinions based on something
other than facts and that's why the
conversations don't go anywhere and so
I'm gonna move on from this one so I'm a
few days late on this but I wanted to
mention one thing about it because I
think there's an element to the ben
shapiro nazi story that that is being
missed so as you probably heard an
anti-semite neo-nazi in Indiana was
sentenced to I think it was three years
in prison a couple days ago for
vandalizing a synagogue in a hate crime
and he he spray-painted I believe he's
pray paid to the swastika and other
nonce Nazi symbols on a synagogue and
he's going to prison for a good reason
for three years now BuzzFeed in the
Washington Post they both tried to tie
the crime to ben shapiro who is of
course an orthodox jew they both
reported that the nazi synagogue
vandalize ur was radicalized by among
other people ben shapiro now this of
course turns out to be totally wrong it
turns out that the guy himself the Nazi
never mentioned anything about ben
shapiro
instead his lawyer in in one document
throw
through Shapiro's name into it claiming
that his wife that the Nazis wife read
Shapiro or something this is obviously
just a weird attempt by the lawyer to
deflect blame which makes sense for the
lawyer to do that's that's the job of a
defense lawyer that's why you hire one
to deflect blame from yourself and so
that's what the defense lawyers doing
but for the media to take this claim and
run with it
uncritically is just I mean words cannot
describe it there is simply no way that
an anti-semite Nazi would be a fan of an
Orthodox Jew and outspoken defender of
Israel there is there's no way period
it's it's a crazy claim and a lot of
people have pointed that out of course
the only thing that I'd like to add to
this discussion is just one brief
thought we may think that it seems crazy
when the left tries to tie ben shapiro
to Nazism or you know any other non Nazi
they try to say all those persons of
Nazi but it's only crazy when you
actually understand Nazism and when you
use words like Nazi and Nazism in an
accurate and rational way now if that's
the the angle that you're approaching
this from then yeah there's no way that
you could bridge that gap between Nazism
and an Orthodox Jew and try to claim
that there's some sort of relationship
there but but that's not how the left
operates that's what we need to
understand when they use the word Nazi
or Nazism they don't mean it the way
that a person who strives for accuracy
in their language might mean it so keep
in mind that the left has turned Nazism
into a broad category which encompasses
well it encompasses actual Nazism so
they will call an actual Nazi a Nazi but
then it also includes literally any view
or perspective that they find
objectionable so they have a broad in
this category into oblivion
take it you know it's started by meaning
especially as a Nazi someone who's
historically either affiliated with the
Nazi Party or someone who now is an
outspoken sympathizer of the Nazi
party's agenda that's what a Nazi is but
on the Left it's gone from meaning that
to meaning
well Nazi has become just sort of
shorthand for a guy with opinions that I
find abhorrent
that's what announced he is now at least
in a lot of people's minds so in that
sense sure Ben Shapiro can inspire Nazis
he can be a Nazi you can be a Nazi I
give me a Nazi half of the country are
Nazis the president is a Nazi because
that's what Nazi means to a lot to a lot
of people when they say it they just
mean well these are all people who have
opinions that I disagree with I find
their opinions terrible I also find the
opinions of Nazis to be terrible and so
they both have terrible opinions and so
they're the same that's the equation and
so that's how you end up with in the
again in the minds of a leftist you you
end up with a you know according to them
there are probably 150 million Nazis
living in this country and it's very
easy to get lumped in there now in
reality of course there are thankfully
only a very very small number of actual
neo-nazis in the country they are a
fringe group a very small group a
dangerous group as we've seen but but
fringe and small but if you think of
someone as Nazi just means well this is
someone I disagree with all of a sudden
they're not so fringe anymore how do we
how do we end up in this place where the
word Nazi has become this catch-all
phrase where people who have nothing to
do at all with historical Nazism and do
not sympathise at all with any of its
agenda
can can somehow get lumped into that
into that category put under that
umbrella how do we end up this way well
I think it's through two things mainly
one is the cheapening the cheapening of
language which is something that I've
talked about a lot plenty of people have
talked about it where it's not just the
word nazi' it's there are many words now
that have the definition of those words
has been expanded to the point of
meaninglessness and we could list a
hundred words like that having a word
like human or a term like human rights
is one in there there are so many where
people there's a sort of lack of
literacy even among people who
technically can read but they don't they
don't sit down to read books they read
memes and tweets and that sort of thing
in text messages and so they're there
their vocabulary has shrunk down
considerably and they only have a few
words to use to describe an emotion or
to or to convey their opposition to a
point of view there are only a few words
they have at their disposal and one of
those words if they want to convey their
opposition one of the words is onazi
do they only they have that word and
like three others and so those are the
only ones they have to choose from so we
have these this shrinking of a
vocabulary cheapening of language and
that's what leads to it and then also an
ignorance of history we all know the
word nazi' we all I think well I was
going to say we all know the basic facts
of World War two but that that actually
probably isn't true but we all know that
World War two happened we know that the
Nazis were involved in it that's
probably the extent of a lot of people's
knowledge and that's the problem that
although we use this word all the time
and we refer back to this historical
event all the time how many people have
actually sat down to say okay let me
understand what actually happened in the
World War two
what happened with the Nazis who were
they what were they doing how did they
come where did they come from
how could this possibly have happened
now these are very important questions
and they're so important that
hundreds and hundreds of books have been
written about them and it's really worth
your time to go and read some of those
books a book that I've think I've got on
a shelf back there that I've recommended
before is the rise and fall of the Third
Reich now when it comes to a book that
helps you to understand where Nazism
came from and how it was able to take
over Germany and then threaten to take
over Europe from there there probably is
no better book to understand that than
the rise and fall of the Third Reich I
mean it's a it's a horrifying and
depressing story of course so it's not a
fun read but it's an important one so my
suggestion is if you're gonna go and run
around and use this word Nazi all the
time and just throw it out willy-nilly
like it doesn't mean anything maybe it
might be worth your time to actually sit
down and understand what that word means
and who these people were because I
think if you do that you're you know if
you sit down and read a book like the
rise of all the Third Reich you you
would not be able to read that book put
it down and then go out and so
flippantly use this word and and just
accuse anyone of being a Nazi accused
ben shapiro being a-- you wouldn't be
able to do it because you now would have
certain a certain amount of wisdom and
understanding and there's just no way
that you would do something that's
stupid
maybe we should all expand our
vocabulary a little bit struggle to
strive to understand history understand
the words and terms we use and the
events that we refer to and and i think
we would all benefit from that all right
um okay but by the way do you know who
Eric salt swallow well is it's okay if
you don't because nobody does he's
running for president and he's polling
at I think think he's polling at 0% last
time I saw but he's attempting to see if
he can basically grovel his way into the
White House hasn't panned out so far but
it's kind of it's it's hilarious though
I'm glad he's in the race because he's
trying to grovel his way in doesn't
and so he just picks he just turns up
the groveling even more and more you're
making it more and more intense hoping
hoping that that somehow it will it will
flip the switch eventually it's pretty
funny to watch here's the latest example
look at this why should another white
guy be President
well white guy who doesn't see other
identities or understand other
experiences should not be President I do
and you know where there would be gaps
and my knowledge or my experience I will
pass the mic to people you know who do
have that experience now here's the
thing about going around parading your
white guilt it's not gonna achieve what
you hope it will achieve because the
people who hate white people will still
hate you
they're bigots and you're not gonna
escape their bigoted wrath by debasing
yourself some anyone out there who
really just hates white men and there
are plenty of people like that you're
not going to apologize them apologize
your way into their good graces now I
don't even know why you'd want to I have
if there's anyone out there who hates
white men I have and they don't like me
I'm fine with that I have no I don't I
don't care if they don't like me I have
no interest in being liked by them I
don't want to be their friend
I don't it's if you're like that I just
I don't to be around you I'm perfectly
fine with you aiding me I'm going to
make no attempt whatsoever to make you
feel better about me because I don't
care you're as you in this case as
someone who hates white men you as a
sexist bigot your opinion means nothing
to me whatsoever your opinion is
worthless it's it is it is the the most
worthless thing in the world honestly
and so I don't care but if for some
reason you do care you should just
realize that debasing yourself in front
of them isn't gonna work and then
everyone else who doesn't hate white
people the people who are not sexist
bigots uh they're they're they will look
at you and cringe they're going to be
embarrassed for you so you would impress
no one there is honestly no cat
Gouri of people who are going to be
impressed by this kind of thing
now the sexist bigots they might take
some kind of and maybe this is where the
confusion comes from the sexist bigots
they do demand that white men apologize
for being why men like Eric swell well
does so they might take some kind of
smug satisfaction in seeing you do that
so that's true but they're still gonna
hate you at the end of it that that part
won't change so you have made them happy
because that they you've humiliated
yourself and they enjoyed watching it
and because they're because they're
bigots but the fact they're bigots isn't
going to change that's the point so it's
just not gonna work
and it certainly won't win you the
presidency I'm afraid as much as I would
enjoy having an in Eric's wall well of
presidency all right speaking of cringe
in this one this is pretty this is
pretty cringe I'm warning you
CBS has a documentary out right now
called period I think the documentary is
just called period but then the or maybe
its period half the population has one
but no one talks about it that's
apparently a full title of it it's like
the subtitle period half the population
hasn't won but no one talks about it and
it's a documentary that talks about
periods and how periods shouldn't be a
taboo subject and we need to talk about
it and there needs to be less unfairness
because it's unfair that women get
periods and men don't and and well
here's a brief clip from that from that
documentary this is a featuring a woman
named Busy Philipps who is famous I
think somehow for some reason watch this
something that happens to half of the
population once a month shouldn't be a
taboo subject I think I mean to be
totally honest and I'm sure I'm not the
first person to say this but like if men
had their periods it would be like he's
celebrated you know would be like a
holiday they would get the week off of
work and probably the week before and
then like the
four days after their period and so that
they could recover it would just be a
different it would just be a different
but men do not get period it's women get
periods yes it's just like so unfair
it's so unfair
you know if men got periods if men got
periods would be like celebrated that's
my Busy Philipps impression pretty good
huh
um well I'm still work shopping and I'm
working a little bit so there you go we
need to we need say oh my gosh her voice
is just can I mean they should take her
down to Guantanamo and have her
interrogate suspected terrorists because
I would not be able to if I had any kind
of secret and she came in with that
voice I break in five minutes I would
just tell you everything I don't care
you well you know whatever it is I'll
I'll give up I'll just yeah
I'll betray any secret just to get out
of that in five minutes okay so we need
to talk about periods more we needed to
celebrate them I've also been told many
times including cluding yesterday as I
was arcing about this on Twitter I was
told that it's not fair that products
for periods cost money and are taxed and
that shouldn't be the case tampons
should be untaxed and possibly even free
because if there were any men if there
were any men only products they would be
untaxed I was told they'd be tax-free if
men had men only products but there are
no men only products apparently because
only women have unique sanitation needs
so it's unfair and and that's the claim
let me see if I can unpack this a little
bit I can't believe that we need to talk
about this but but fine I'm game let's
let's talk about it number one do we
actually need to talk about periods now
I I say this as a man and I understand
that although and I'm look I'm just
leaving aside the fact that you just
heard in the clip there well what men
don't get periods women do no how many
times do I have to say it's a leftist
you're not allowed to say things like
that anymore you can't I for
you're not allowed to say it you
can'tyou that's not what you believe
remember that is not your own belief
system how many times have to remind you
of your own belief system that's not
what you believe no you think that men
can't have periods remember remember
that whole thing you can't just put that
to the side you can't do that no you you
can't or unfortunately you can now if
we're up to me that you wouldn't be able
to if I if I could impose you know what
yeah if I could impose intellectual
consistency by law if I could force it
by Allah if I could punish if I could
legally punish intellectual
inconsistency I would if I could put
people in jail for it I would that's how
much I hate it that's how much I hate it
when people when they say one thing here
and then they make another argument that
completely contradicts that argument yet
they try to keep that argument intact
they try to keep both and just switch
back and forth no you're not allowed to
you don't think that Busy Philipps you
like don't think that okay that's not
actually like your point of view all
right okay actually men can get periods
just if maybe I need to express it in
language you'll understand so but I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to put that to the
side as much as the intellectual
consistency enrages me with a deep fiery
anger I am going to try to suppress it
we'll put that to the side okay so we
need to talk about okay what do you need
to say about it what what do you need to
tell us exactly about your bodily
functions I mean what is what do you
think the conversation will consist of
what does it need to consist of how much
discussion do we need to have because I
feel like we do actually talk about it a
lot now here this is CBS doesn't
document no one talks about periods well
first of all even if nobody did talk
about them great who cares but what do
you but people do talk about
I mean you just made a documentary about
them there's there aren't a lot of
documentaries about other bodily
functions where is the flatulence
documentary flatulence everyone has it
no one talks about it no so people do
talk about it it seems to me people talk
about it a lot now ladies you can
correct me but it is is it not the case
that this is actually something that
women talk about am I just imagining
things
now generally speaking though and maybe
this is what you're kind of picking up
on it is not considered polite or decent
or normal to go around in public talking
about your bodily functions any bodily
function it doesn't matter what the
function is especially any bodily
function that involves any bodily fluid
excreting from any part of your body I'm
not trying to be graphic here but but I
mean if I have to explain these basic
rules of social decorum then I will if
if anything is happening if there is any
kind of fluid exiting your body in any
form whatsoever then it that's not
something you need to have a discussion
about okay I'll make an exception if you
just got shot and there is blood pouring
out of your stomach okay then yes you
probably should talk about that to
somebody like for instance 9-1-1 and
then the doctor so that is something
that need to be discussed but for the
most part it's it's not something you
need to go around talking other people
about you know if you're if you pass by
someone in the supermarket you don't
need to stop them and say can I tell you
about my bodily fluids you don't need to
there's no reason because here's the
thing the person that you've des passing
by you in the supermarket they I can
guarantee you 100% of the time they
don't need to hear about it they don't
want to eat they definitely weren't
wondering when they were Pat they
weren't passing by you when thinking I
wonder what's going on with that
person's bodily fluids I hope they'll
tell me about it they they weren't
thinking that I guarantee you they
weren't thinking you know what they were
thinking they were thinking oh where's
the spaghetti aisle they must have moved
the spaghetti you know that's what
they're thinking something like that not
about you
especially not about your fluids so
that's the first thing
there are many fluids that come out of
many areas of the body and generally we
don't throw prayed parade to celebrate
it like nobody goes nobody goes hey I'm
sweating under my armpit hey everybody
look sweat throw a parade call the press
call the president say hooray hooray for
me no one does that no one does it
because that would be gross and weird
and and you know there's a reason why we
tend to think of bodily fluids as gross
there's actually a good reason now I
know you say well we should break the
taboo it's normal everyone does it yeah
but it's it's it's actually still gross
and it's important it's important that
we think it's gross because any kind of
bodily fluid carries germs and diseases
and so that's why we have developed this
strong desire to clean them and to keep
them away from other people and to be
sanitary and to sort of isolate those
things from other people because it's
it's that's just basic sanitation it's
basic survival defecation is something
everyone does
totally normal it's all so disgusting
and and there's a reason again why we
think it's disgusting because if you
didn't think that yours was disgusting
then you become a biohazard to everybody
around you so should we break the taboo
no no let's keep the taboo in place
that's a very good taboo that the taboo
around you know bowel movements it's a
great taboo I'm a huge fan of that taboo
because it means that if you got to do
that you're gonna go to a private place
it's called a bathroom special little
place picked out or you can go and you
could take care of that don't need to
tell anybody don't need to announce it
just go do it take care of it wash your
hands boom good taboo great just the
second thing though because this this is
you you've probably heard this before
about how well you know women women's
sanitary products should be tax-free
because a kind of a common idea now
because it's a necessity and it's unique
to them and why should they be penalized
and so on and so forth
this again is very stupid first of all
toilet paper as we've referenced is a
necessity also yet it's not free and it
is text deodorant I would think is a
necessity for most people and it is not
free either and it's text there is
literally an entire industry there's a
whole industry that produces these
bathroom products and none of it is free
so why should women's products be
excluded from that so you know you're
not asking for equality
once again you're asking for special
treatment you want something everyone
else doesn't get and men don't have
their own men you know men's products
really there is a whole aisle in any
drugstore consisting of men's toiletry
products okay there's a whole aisle of
it none of it is free I Got News for You
we can't just walk down that aisle just
grab whatever old spice just throw it in
walk out not pay for it doesn't work
that way we got to pay for it it's taxed
that's the way it goes and by the way
men do have their own unique hygiene and
sanitation needs for instance we grow as
you can see thick beards on our faces
now almost no woman does some women do
grow some facial hair but oh well almost
no woman without the aid of drugs would
grow this I know there are a few
exceptions out there but you know back
in the day they used to be in circuses
but almost no woman does this is a
pretty this is pretty unique to men
right this whole situation right here
and yeah here's the thing I'm a big
beard supporter as you know I believe in
beards I think beards are great but I
also know that I can't just let it go
and and do nothing for a month
it's not like with women where you know
women like to brag that they'll go like
a month in the winter and not shave
their legs because I can wear pants or a
long skirt we can't do that with the
hair on our face this is unique to us we
have a unique situation
and it's it's the case for pretty pretty
much any man with few exceptions that if
if if pretty much any man were to go 1
or 2 months without doing anything any
form of shaving or trimming on the face
they would look like Tom Hanks from cast
away and they would be unemployable they
would be outcasts in society they would
look unkempt and and bad and they'd be
judged for it so what do we need to do
that means what we need to many of us
every day we got to trim the beard you
got to shave different you know I would
grow a whole like neck beard if I didn't
shave this part right here so and that's
something we have to do every day you
know it's it's it is basically a need
that we have in order to remain
civilized members of society and to
remain employable and all these other
other things women don't have that need
men do yet shaving products are
extremely expensive if you've never had
to buy male shaving products they are
expensive and and they give you you get
like a razor then they give you one
extra blade and then the blade goes dull
in about 32 seconds and then you got to
go out and buy a whole pack of new
blades and the new blades cost you know
one hundred and seventy dollars a piece
I'm exaggerating slightly but it is
expensive is the point and we have to do
it it's not free its tax we got to do it
and that's just that's just the way it
is it's it's am I gonna say it's unfair
like when I'm shaving in them in the
morning
am i weeping and this is so unfair women
don't have my wife doesn't have to do
this this is so unfair
no I'm glad my wife doesn't have to do
this every morning that would make me
pretty upset okay if I came in one
morning and I saw my wife with shaving
cream all over her face you know doing
this that would make me cry that part I
would cry over that the fact that I'm
the only one who shaves good for me I'm
fine with that
that's just biology it's not unfair it's
not any quality no one's being
victimized it's just it's
it's just the hand you were dealt bye
bye bye it is just the biological hand
you were dealt and all you can do is
deal with it alright uh let's say we
have a bunch of emails don't have time
for a lot of them but okay we'll do this
one this is a good question from Joe
says or Matt Walsh show at gmail.com is
the email address Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Joe says hello
Matt I wanted to ask you two questions
about very polarizing topics one what
are your top five favorite western
movies I'm a huge fan of westerns - what
are your favorite root beers I'm just
starting to get into trying different
root beers I'm looking for suggestions
great questions Joe okay favorite
westerns I'm not gonna put them in order
I'll just give you my you know five my
five that I like the most five favorite
so The Searchers Shane open range
hostels up with us it's a new one I'll
put that in there good the bad and the
ugly is that five or six already and
then I would also put the assassination
of Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford
which is not a standard Westar came out
you know relatively recent came back in
like a 2006 or 2007 and I thought that
was a very Affleck and and Brad Pitt as
Jesse James how that was a very good
movie two beautiful movies
cinematography is just incredible in
that movie so that would be I think
that's six that I named
and surprisingly three of my six were
made in the lab or made in this century
which is interesting and then if I could
include miniseries as well I would say
Lonesome Dove which my favorite Western
story in any medium would be Lonesome
Dove so that would be it's not not
technically a movie but I put that in a
boy as far as root beers I'm no expert
in the subject but certainly as for mass
produced root beers that you can get at
the grocery store the ibc root beers in
the glass bottles are clearly superior
to any other offering that you're going
to
find and so I think that's obviously the
answer there and this is from Tim says
Matt I've always been fascinated by
other people's jobs I've always wondered
what they do at work a few questions for
you okay I'll try to answer these as I
read them because it's a bunch of
questions how many emails do you get
it's hard to say I say hundreds a week I
don't know exactly how many I don't
count do you read them all yourself or
does someone read them for you and
curate them curate them I read the
emails myself but definitely not all of
them it's a probably read about 15
percent of them do you do you get it do
you get a few to choose from and then
pick the ones that you want to answer
well again I choose myself I decide
which ones to open based on how
interesting the subject line is and then
I decide from there how do you decide
which to pick well if it's it's so which
to pick to answer on the show well if
it's a question I haven't gotten before
then I'll almost definitely address it
on the show regardless of what the
question is even if it's not it doesn't
matter if it's just a question I haven't
had like this one if it's an interesting
perspective on something even if it's
not a like you don't have to email me a
question this isn't a question and
answer session necessarily you could
just have it an opinion about something
that we talked about and I'll read that
if it's if it's interesting and
well-written and and if it's funny
I'll read it or if it's really vicious
hate mail most the time I'll read that
stuff because I appreciate the effort
and that's basically my front formula
and he says how far in advance do you
prepare to answer an email honestly as
you can probably tell not very far in
advance at all like not I don't prepare
at all actually I just I put down the
emails I want to answer and I have them
here on my computer and then I just
answer I read them over once before I
start the show but I don't usually put a
lot of effort into it which is not meant
to be you know it's it's just because
I'm lazy is the only reason how big is
your staff well my staff consists of
zero people oh that's how big it is do
they work at your house well I guess
they don't because they don't exist
so it might and this is my staff right
here you can see this is me I am my
my staff all right um actually my staff
now I guess is the guard of the crutches
that are on the ground there okay I
guess we'll leave it there I had a bunch
of other interesting quite including a
question about this this Martin Luther
King stuff which is pretty horrific but
I will leave that we'll talk because
that needs more time to address and I
will leave that for tomorrow as well as
the other emails thank you all for
watching Godspeed
hey everybody's Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show Robert Muller has
made a statement and James Comey has
written an op-ed for the Washington Post
and both former FBI guys have made it
clear they don't like Donald Trump and
they think their investigations were
peachy keen and I think we should listen
very carefully to what they have to say
before we make a final decision as to
how many of these guys we can send to
prison where they belong that's on the
Andrew Clavin show plus the mailbag I'm
Andrew Clavin